uh as you say exposed to all sorts of
different religions and different
churches in your youth what is it about
the Free Church that attracted you that
Drew you there just down the road so um
it's the it's the closest church I've
always been
um Keen to uh support the church that
was on my doorstep forgive me
you're obviously someone whose religion
and your faith is really important to
you into your life and all of those
things of course and you're you really
are saying that the reason that you
chose the church that you're with now is
just because it was down the road there
must be more to it than that surely
I I hate to disappoint you but um and
obviously anybody would be welcome to
visit the highlands but a a having
having lived I lived just near Dingle
and it is the church I mean I've not
made any uh sort of not made any effort
to hide my faith in the six years that
I've been in Frontline politics indeed
all my constituents know
um about my faith and yet they have
elected me